today's meeting is the important first
opportunity to express the opinions of a
member states I believe that this is
realistic and time of crisis and
consolidation of a public finances
versus also ambitious how to finance
more Europe with more or less the same
money and we have more Europe now we
fully support the idea of finding more
resources in the period of crisis and
difficulty for all our member states in
the European Union we support the idea
of project bonds and facilitating a
mixed in venture investment so these are
issues that we support the economic
challenge of today called for free size
of the budget and new policy focus
because in time of national body
consolidation there is no room for
increased contributions to the EU budget
as our position conditionality is the
key word of the day maybe even of the
decade in the you and I cannot see this
not being reflected also in the cohesion
policy for hungry the overall decrease
of cohesion envelope is unacceptable
given the fact that most of the other
expenditure elements are suggested to be
raised Hungary is very critical towards
the general feature of the Commission
proposal la belgique Appel qg3 New Hope
en el principal ma boo Jadhav St small
is a rooster modesty smock renewables
Whomper your decrees la politique the
comb on federal treaty constituted the
pileated oppose darvis the small elite
viva la politique de cuisine
Ravi Andre assertive a lab in Val de
l'épée connecting Europe facility we
think it's a very good thing that large
amounts will be earmarked for transport
energy and telecom after all those areas
are key if we are to have proper
integration of these funds within the
European Union that that was the case
with the creation of the modern
nation-state without transport without
energy
you you get nowhere our member states
would not exist as they do today let
alone the European Union a few words of
the Common Agricultural Policy the Czech
Republic suppose simplification and
redaction of a mr. burden the welcome
the heat of our kept funding proposed by
the Commission happily codifies
functioning a la France Kiawah
documentation substantial degree D come
to two new de la situación the national
public directly publish it among a cozy
content based on digital history animal
convey young in augmentation foster the
jibiji opium Salafis imported Cal Newton
on Baku
I mean top-down approach for the next
financial framework we need to introduce
a greater level of simplification and we
believe that in this respect we should
not be changing without a specific
reason those provisions that have so far
worked well we need to avoid a double
sanction on those countries in the euro
zone with the sanctions under the
six-pack together with suspension of
monies paid from funds we need to think
of the future so we can only spend more
legitimately where we are contributing
to growth and competitiveness of the EU
it's not enough just have austerity
austerity measures that's true we need
growth and jobs but that must be that
must be expressed here so for
forward-looking projects in particular
in research and innovation education
environment climate energy transfer
appear networks there's the sort of
areas I have on agricultural policy and
Fisheries we think that the proposals
put forward by the Commission
are good some of the notions or greening
are good
we must however try to avoid all kinds
of unnecessary bureaucracy the common
agriculture policy I would like to make
a point on convergence we believe that
the distribution is an important step
but it in its current form and the
reduction of disparities is too small
important differences up to 3/4 times
remaining between the minimum and the
maximum payment allocated to Member
States as we've often been stressed the
Commission proposals are a basis for
negotiations but the final result has to
lie below the Commission proposals
Austria is very much in favor of a
top-down approach ladies and gentlemen
we are where we are because of the
dawning realization that we cannot live
beyond our means I think we know that
well from our domestic private budgets
we have to understand that in a national
level and apparently we need to
understand it at a European level as
well so the quicker we understand that
we cannot live beyond our means the
easier it will be to handle the crisis
in Europe we strongly agree with those
who have emphasized the importance of a
top-down approach you need to decide the
size of the overall envelope and then
work out the priorities within that it's
very difficult to do it the other way
around on the Common Agricultural Policy
we are particularly concerned with the
disproportionate costs for
implementation of greening measures and
we also believe that the rate of direct
payment per hectare criterion would need
to be calibrated to take into account
member state specificities concerning
land issues we believe that cohesion
policy is the engine that pulls a Europe
2020 strategy and from our point of view
the cohesion policy is one of the most
important instruments for reaching our
agreed goals starting point for us we
want an effective budget future proof
with fair distribution of the burden and
the proposals by the Commission are
considered to be a good basis for
discussion crucial elements for us is
the overall proposed expenditure level
is too high
we favor a top-down approach as others
have advocated here which first
determines the affordable levels of
expenditure in line with the economic
circumstances we sort like a nice 2018
Bond bass ball in excess for future
noblemen considering bond proposition at
the beginning I just want to remind all
of us that we are looking at the
Montaigne financial framework with a
nine year perspective up to year to 2020
and I think that this is our
responsibility to secure condition has
to apply across the board to all the
proposal on the Common Agricultural
Policy seems to neglect the interest of
Levine and other member states those
level of direct payments is
significantly lower now and will stay
almost twice lower until 2020 this would
force our farmers to compete in those
conditions than those in other number
states in the single market lishchyna
cannot agree to the proposal cohesion
policy like the Common Agricultural
Policy enables our citizens to clearly
see the benefits that the Union brings
to them we agree that the focus on
results in the Commission proposal on
cohesion is essential however the way in
which the conditionalities will apply
must not undermine the key Europe 2020
aim of promoting of growth or lead to an
excessive administrative burden Cyprus
does not support provisions relating to
micro economic condition a letís we we
reiterate out our view that linky
cohesion policy to macroeconomic
conditions could result in suspending
community investment resources for
member states that are most in need
the EU budget must be modernized we
should prioritize policies that support
the growth and jobs agenda for instance
research and innovation and we should
also focus more on policies that
underpin the green agenda for instance
the environment climate and energy this
is only possible if we have the courage
to make real change thank you thank you
and I close this meeting